you said it looks a lot like the 1940s
maybe talk a little bit just about what
was happening in the 40s and the 70s
that you see a lot of similarities those
were the two inflationary decades of the
past century in the united states in the
1970s that's what a lot of people think
of as the inflationary decade but it's
actually a somewhat less viable example
here it has some overlap obviously so in
the 70s debt as a percentage of gdp at
that point was very low they had already
inflated away a lot of debt from the 40s
50s
and so actually you know public debt as
a percentage of gdp was something like
30 percent private debt wasn't that bad
either and so overall you had a pretty
low debt environment but you had other
issues obviously so basically they they
had you know spent decades drawing down
their gold reserves to to you know
support the bretton wood system which is
what the dollar was pegged to gold and
they couldn't really back that anymore
and two u.s oil production peaked in
1970 representing a real world
constraint they had to import more of
their oil basically you had this this
combined scenario where they you know
they went off the gold standard so that
broke the money system and then they
actually had that inflationary component
of oil restrictions and then also there
were geopolitical issues obviously in
the middle east and so for a while that
was a very inflationary period and as
you can see on the chart there the fed
kept trying to raise interest rates uh
to combat inflation um but they were
generally you know they weren't decisive
with it they were slow they kept saying
is transitory uh sounds familiar um and
so they fought this for a while and it
wasn't until the very end where a number
of factors relating to demographics as
well as pulver volcker coming in and
jacking up interest rates super high he
basically put the economy into recession
in order to stabilize the the dollar the
purchasing power uh so that that's how
that decade went now if we go back to
the 40s it was a different environment
because
most of the inflation was driven by
fiscal spending whereas in the 70s it
was a combination of a lot of things as
part of the fiscal spending a lot of it
was bank loan growth right whereas in
the 40s it was almost entirely gigantic
war spending
and so we often think of war spending as
foreign spending but actually most of it
is spending on the domestic economy
they're building factories they're
paying for gi bills uh you know a lot of
the programs are somewhat similar to
what we saw over the past year and a
half
but obviously tailored towards more
industrial purposes
and so you had this this massive
increase the money supply from the
fiscal spending which was monetized by
the fed and so you had an actual you had
an inflationary component especially
because also every country in the world
was trying to get as many commodities as
they could right so there's a lot of
commodity demand
and so you had a very inflation
environment the difference was that
because federal debt as a percentage of
gdp was a hundred and thirty percent
they could raise interest rates to five
percent or ten percent or higher because
it would bankrupt the government so they
they had no choice they just had the
whole interest rates low
despite the fact that inflation was high
and so if you were holding cash or
treasuries you just got annihilated on
an inflation-adjusted basis for like
that for like a nine year period where
they just held rates super low even
though inflation peaked at 19
year-over-year in the 40s uh and the
overall average inflation for that
decade was about six percent and you
just sat there earning roughly zero
percent of your t bills and roughly two
and a half percent on your longer longer
dated treasury bonds so when you look at
this uh you had a second tweet that
basically said this is the widest gap
that we've had on record uh and you'd
have to go back to the 40s and kind of
situation you're talking about there is
your thought process that we now are
entering the exact same situation where
they're gonna have to keep the rates low
uh for a decade or so and we can look to
the 40s as the actual guide for what to
expect moving forward or do you think
there's some similarities but we may get
uh kind of a different outcome or a
different action one they obviously have
the hindsight of what happened in the
40s and 70s but also they may have some
uh some different thoughts in terms of
what to do moving forward so i find that
that the 40s is the most instructive
analogy to be familiar with basically i
would say it's not going to be identical
to that there are differences that i can
go over but anyone who's not familiar
with the 40s is going to be for a rough
time i think and and confused about
markets um and so it's a useful period
to study in terms of fiscal monetary
policy so i would say in those areas
fiscal monetary policy it's likely to be
very similar to the to the 1940s there
are some differences and and so
obviously there's a different
geopolitical environment we're not in a
world war instead there's you know
basically spending related to you know
uh
lockdown things and and basically fiscal
stimulus in that regard so there's still
kind of similar fiscal environment but
it's for different purposes uh there's
very different demographics in the
developed world right so you have much
older population and so some of these
structural deficits um
aren't really going to go away anytime
soon uh whereas in the in the at the end
of world war ii they were able to
eventually you know get their deficit
away at least for several years
um and so
there's differences there and another uh
difference is that the united states
back then was a creditor nation and a
trade surplus nation so we were like a
rising power we were producing more than
we were importing uh and we owned more
foreign assets than foreign of our
assets uh whereas in this period the
united states is the world's biggest
debtor nation where you have a
structural trade deficit so in some ways
we actually look more like the united
kingdom looked in the 1940s uh meaning
that we you know they were the existing
kind of world reserve currency they are
the ones running structural trade
deficits um and and the united states
was counting to china back then they
were the one that were that was coming
up with massive gdp growth they were the
ones you know making things for the
world um and so the the roles are
somewhat flipped here so there are
important differences to be aware of i
think one final difference is that in
terms of the equity market it's a pretty
different environment because we went
into the 40s
equity evaluations were very low you
just came out of the 1930s depressionary
period
and then obviously the the beginning of
the war years were not going very well
so basically until there were major
victories in the pacific equities were
very very low valued and they started to
rise after that when you had these
inflationary pressures and a week and
when it became increasingly obvious that
the united states was going to
win the war um and that things were
going to go you know pretty well at the
end uh and so going into this
environment obviously it's it's very
high equity valuations
and in many ways that actually does look
closer to the 70s because you had very
very high valuations in the late 60s
early 70s going into that inflationary
period
and so that can certainly affect how
equities perform on an
inflation-adjusted basis between these
two environments